hello everybody I'm Jesse Watters along
with dr. Nicole sapphire Juan Williams
Dana Perino and Greg Gutfeld
it's five o'clock in New York City and
this is the five
[Music]
a major Senate showdown over if America
will hear from both Supreme Court
nominee Brett Kavanaugh and his accuser
Senate Republicans setting a hearing for
next Monday the Democrats are making new
demands they now want more time more
witnesses to testify and for the FBI to
investigate the 36 year old allegation
president Trump reacting to it all
earlier you don't wait till the hearing
is over and then all of a sudden bring
it up when senator Feinstein sat with
judge Kavanaugh for a long period of
time a long long meeting she had this
letter why didn't she bring it up why
didn't she bring it up then why didn't
the Democrats bring it up then because
they obstruct and because there is this
that's the name of their campaign
against me they're lousy on policy and
in many ways they're lousy politicians
but they're very good on obstruction we
should go through a process because they
shouldn't even be a little doubt
lawmakers are trading blows over how
this process is playing out it is still
disturbing now ever to think about the
way in which this has developed right at
the end and it's pretty obvious this is
all about delaying the process we cannot
continue the victimization and the
smearing smearing of someone like dr.
Ford and you know what she is under no
obligation to participate we wouldn't
find ourselves nor would the dr. Ford
find herself in this situation if
senator Feinstein hadn't sat on this
letter she's had since July I think the
nomination should be withdrawn he has
raised serious doubts about his
credibility
well so far Republicans say lawyers for
Christine Blasi Ford have not responded
to their invitation for her to testify
and Mark judge the other person alleged
to be in the room says he doesn't
remember the incident or the party and
will not testify okay so before we get
into the political stuff I want to ask
the doctor a question and dr. Gutfeld
brought this up yesterday about the
memory situation so tell me what you
think about this as a licensed
professional
she doesn't really recall how she got to
the party she doesn't recall the house
that the party was thrown in and she
doesn't recall how she got home from the
party she's a little fuzzy about the
people that were there at the time and
there was some discrepancy with the
notes that her therapist took and she
admits that she was drinking now with
that said she believes and I believe she
believes that something happened that
night but what role does memory play in
the passage of time with an allegation
this serious it's a great question and
let's be clear I'm not a psychologist
psychiatrist or involved in this case
whatsoever that's my medical disclaimer
however it is a well-known fact that
people when something traumatic happens
to them or something that happens a long
time ago when you're in your doctor's
room they deliver some news that the
moment you leave you don't necessarily
remember the details you don't remember
the facts add a not fully formed frontal
lobe add alcohol and then add 36 years
to that and I obviously details can get
muddied a little bit do I believe
something happened to dr. Ford in her
adolescence absolutely I don't think
anybody's ready to deny that whatsoever
but I do think it's interesting that the
party of Bill Clinton and keith Ellison
are trying to lecture America that we
need to have a potentially politically
motivated allegations should derail an
entire process here and I have concerns
about that because we want to ask
questions get answers but she doesn't
have the answers and so it's going to go
into a he-said she-said well here's the
problem though
so she says she can't remember some of
the details that jesse rightly laid out
but he says of a party that nobody
murmurs the details that he wasn't there
well that's not logical wait a second so
nobody knows exactly where the party
took place and you don't remember being
there well how can you wait that didn't
make that's that's that's the that's the
trick and it's you can't blame it if you
say you did this to me I can't tell you
when or where because then if I do you
might be able to say I wasn't there and
that wasn't me so you leave that
intentionally vague no I would think I
would think that I would say that never
happened
nobody also said I wasn't there
no she wasn't there because it didn't
happen I would say that the other point
is that you know having watched this
before in my life I just think it's
proper to say that it's very difficult
given what dr. Singh was saying about
memory very difficult for people who
have been traumatized and hurt then to
come forward in the first place and know
they're going to be pilloried that she
is in though she's in the arena right
now you could not be more at the
mountaintop with arrows flying from
every direction there's a difference
between skepticism in pilloried
everybody has if everybody can go on
social media and condemn something
people can go on social media and
question something and I think that like
if even like senator Blumenthal he
should know better about the fal ability
of memory this is a guy who sincerely I
will give him that believed he went to
Vietnam but he actually didn't go we
change our memories I said it yesterday
our memory is Plato but I will say this
to your point that goes both ways her
memory has gaps and so could his so they
so that's why something has to be
reported when it happens this is the
problem you can't relying on something
that happened three and a half decades
ago in the court of public opinion means
every single human being on this planet
is vulnerable to this thing and the
Democrats Dana said they want the FBI to
go back and investigate this but the FBI
has said this isn't really something we
do this is something a local law
enforcement would do what's the play
here next well if an actually if you
want to learn a little bit more about
the FBI piece Kim's Drossel The Wall
Street Journal had a series of tweets
today explaining the FBI's jurisdiction
its role and how it does background
checks there's been six of them on Brett
Kavanaugh in the last 15 years it's not
ever come up before this is not a
jurisdictional issue for them that would
have been local law enforcement the
Democrats were saying the FBI needs to
reopen it and they well what would we
what would we do so now you have a
situation where the Senators have said
on the Republican side we'll have
another hearing we'll do it Monday we'll
do it quickly because Brett Cavanaugh
says I'm anxious to clear my name
they still haven't heard from dr. Ford's
lawyers or from her as to whether she
will show it the Senators also said you
don't have to do it
an open hearing we can do it as a closed
session so you don't even you won't have
to worry about you know this idea that
you're going to be paraded around and
there will be some kind of a circus and
I am curious about one thing senator
Hirono the Democrat from Hawaii she said
that dr. Ford is under no obligation to
prove anything she doesn't have to say
anything well then why then is the
burden of proof on Brett Kavanaugh and
if it is on him that let him testify and
if she doesn't come I think that they do
what they can to try to get the
information and if the Democrats decide
that they're going to vote against so
much they already said they were going
to call the vote well you know Orrin
Hatch says he doesn't believe her I mean
I think that's premature but I do think
that in most cases like this and so
let's try to step away from the politics
for a second if there was such an
incident an assault typically you would
have somebody from the local police
right special victims go in there and
try to figure out what actually took
place so in this situation I think it
cries out given all the political static
in the air for somebody to say here's
what we were able to discern by talking
to people talking it's just that's what
a hearing closed or open I meant like
some law enforcement people they say 36
years ago they don't even know the year
that the party was suppose I thought
they did know the year because she was
15 he was 17 but it's it's if it was a
local law enforcement issue the statute
of limitations have way expired so I
don't even think you could even
prosecute a crime if there were a crime
in this part it's not prosecution right
but I'm saying if you were to even look
at it
this will set a guilty until proven
innocent precedent if this successfully
derails nomination that's why she says
that's when senator Hirono says that the
accuser is under no obligation and we
are to just okay then what are we
supposed to do just to say okay well
there's a accusation with with that
something happened but we don't know all
of these details and therefore exactly
when I was allowed to ever go forward
you can't prove or disprove it they're
just it's just out there now Jonathan
trophies
that the tie goes to the accuser so if
it's he said she said that the tie goes
that yeah is that the new station this
is it there's there's a certain kind of
public display going on where people are
saying that it has it's if it's he said
she said it must always be she said if
that's the case then we don't really
need to have courts anymore we can just
do a priority of innocence on what group
is more innocent than the other and get
rid of courts this is about winning for
a party at any cost and the cost is is
perhaps ruining a life
I saw a headline I won't say where it's
from that said the headline was this our
Republicans really going to nominate an
accused rapist to overturn Roe okay so
think about I would ask the people on
both sides imagine if this was your son
dad or brother we often think about you
know victims but but would you
characterize this as fair without with
with the knowledge that we have right
now is it fair to characterize somebody
that way if that is your if that is your
husband your brother your son or your
father and I said think sometimes well
all the time in politics we don't think
that way and we will ruin somebody's
life just so we can get somebody on the
door so to era this has become a little
bit more common and we've seen in the
past yeah I was gonna say I agree with
you that to me though the thing about it
is you know historically women say you
know men you don't get it you don't hear
us you don't listen to us right and then
you get this cultural surge I saw it
with a Nita Hill and I'm seeing it again
that's a different era but it's again do
we as men listen do we hear and it's
very difficult because this is about
culture you said it's just about one
side winning I think by the way you
could reverse it that Republicans just
want to get this out of the way inhabit
you here if they're not willing to come
and talk well that's the question
you raise an important point today is
she willing to testify we thought she
was now her attorney won't say and also
we just because you're skeptical does
not mean you're not listing you may be
really listening more listening as much
as possible because I said this before I
believe something happened but I believe
memory is having an effect either with
him or with her the whole is going to be
listening on Monday because it's going
to be
one for the history books